it's happening a supporter of domestic
terrorists is now on the homeland
security committee Marjorie Taylor green
the radical republican congresswoman a
joke of a woman making the United States
a global laughingstock who defended and
supported the domestic terrorists who
stormed the capital on January 6th of
2021 who pushed 9 11 conspiracy theories
who talked about Jewish space lasers she
will sit on the homeland security
committee the woman that said they would
have been armed and would have won if
she led the January 6th coup
is now on the homeland security
committee the homeland security
committee should be investigating people
like Marjorie Taylor green but it is
Marjorie Taylor green who in this
backwards United States ends up on that
very committee who does she think are
the threats people like Hunter Biden
people who she claims are socialists and
Communists even though they are not you
know the drill Rolling Stone reporting
the new GOP controlled house is letting
liars and conspiracy theorists lead its
agenda that is exactly right Kevin
McCarthy the new Speaker of the House
indicated he will allow Congressman
George Santos currently facing multiple
investigations for lying to voters about
his identity to also have a committee
position we're going to get to that
later on in the program
Rolling Stone reminds us green was
removed from the house education and
labor committee and the budget Committee
in February of 21 over backlash from
statements she made before her election
including that a Bullet to the Head was
the quickest way to remove Nancy Pelosi
from her then speakership green was also
revealed to Harbor a belief in Q Anon
having spread conspiracy theories about
mass shootings and suggested 9 11 was a
hoax green will now serve on the
homeland security committee I think it's
great Kevin McCarthy reportedly said on
Tuesday
some of Green's priorities she recently
said to Tucker Carlson she believes that
current Department of Homeland Security
secretary majorcus should be impeached
Paul gozar is also on the committee for
natural resources he was censured by the
house and ousted after he tweeted that
anime battle sequence where
um Alexandria ocasio-cortez was killed
Kevin McCarthy sure had to cut some
pretty damn wild deals to get those
votes and become speaker of the house
that is abundantly clear this is the
United States of America in 2023. you
support a failed coup you defend the
rioters you say if you had been in
charge of the coup you would have won
the coup you get to stay in congress by
the way
and then you get a job on the committee
in charge of Homeland Security
this is where we are and what of her
experience even ostensibly qualifies for
her for this role is it the harassment
she engaged in of the victims of school
shootings does that qualify her to be on
the homeland security committee is it
any of the long list of things we've
talked about before it is embarrassing
that this is where the country is and
you know how it'll go two years from now
we'll look back and we'll say what are
Marjorie Taylor Green's accomplishments
on this committee
and there will be none nothing positive
anyway and then they will say well we
couldn't get anything done because of
Democrats in the senate or whatever but
definitely vote for me again because now
I'm part of the in group and that's
really what this is about from Audrey
Taylor green and also that's a lot of
the of the Catalyst for this new war
she's engaged in with fellow lunatic
congresswoman Lauren bobert and that's
what I want to talk about next
you might remember that a few years ago
uh the show got hacked and many
thousands of dollars were stolen we
never got it back it's a terrible
feeling it can happen to anyone but a
couple of years ago we got Aura which
really gives a significantly more peace
of mind and our sponsor Aura is the app
that protects you from scammers by
alerting you anytime your info like
email passwords social security number
are found in data breaches or also
automatically requests removal of your
info from search engines and it can
reduce spam calls Aura alerts you
quickly about suspicious credit
inquiries like if someone tries to take
a loan out in your name and or as
password manager makes it easy to keep
your account secure to begin with aura
also has parental controls for your kids
devices you can restrict apps or manage
screen time set Focus time make sure
they're doing homework instead of
binging on YouTube you can try Aura free
for 14 days at aura.com Pacman use the
free trial to see if your email password
are already out there you may be
surprised the link is down below